hey everyone and welcome to another HD
tutorial in this video I'll be showing
you how to upgrade your current version
of Google Earth and get Google Earth 5.0
you might have already heard about this
it's a new version of Google Earth that
allows you to yes explore the ocean and
even parts of Mars so first when you
open Google this should be right at the
bottom if you're watching this video
recently if not just type in Google
Earth 5.0 the most recent version and
it'll be at earth.google.com
so once you've clicked on this and the
whole entire link opens It'll ask you if
you want to download Google Earth 5.0
and obviously I do want to download it
so I'm going to hit download I already
have Google Earth
so here it's going to say a green
download and I open it download is done
opening
is going to sense whether or not I have
a version of Google Earth already so I'm
going to exit out of
I'm going to hit Run exit exit
so now we're going to wait for the
installer now uh UAC just popped up
asking me if I wanted to continue and I
hit uh continue of course uh this did
not show up in camstudio because it is
invisible to that screen recorder now
we're going to wait for the installer to
show up here this says Google upgraders
contacting the server please wait so
I'll come back to you guys when it's
done
and also you might notice it says
downloading update it doesn't say it's
actually downloading Google Earth
because if I go under installed software
it knows I already have Google Earth
so right now it's just downloading an
update for Google Earth which will end
up being Google Earth 5.0 so be right
back
all right when the installation is
complete just hit run Google Earth and
it'll open
also you may have noticed it I've
actually put a desktop icon on my
background
so here it's open Google Earth new
splash screen you can see and keep in
mind I'm using a screen recorder so it's
not going to be the smoothest video in
the world but you can see that Google
Earth has actually opened up I'm
actually going to try to go down in the
ocean here
may not work
well it appears that I'm underwater but
uh you get the point it's Google Earth
5.0 and whenever you hit your um Google
Earth uh what do you want to call it a
shortcut it'll always open the same
Google Earth I'm just going to replace
that shortcut so you guys know so um
that is the only way I know of how to
upgrade your current version of Google
Earth or to just get work
um for free at the website that I showed
you
um so yeah thanks for watching peace